der künstlerische newsletter von alisa
läufer über die brutale polizeigewalt in
russland der verantwortliche ist
ausgemacht der autoritäre kremlchef
wladimir putin geht mit gewalt gegen
seine kritiker und andersdenkende vor
die 33 jährige nennt sich politische
social media künstlerin und dokumentiert
die exklusiven geschehnisse in russland
seit der rückkehr des oppositionellen
alexei navalny nachdem ein giftanschlag
auf ihn missglückt war
nun wollen immer mehr leute den
machtwechsel im moment scheint er nur
mit gewalt möglich denn die polizei geht
hart vor menschen werden abgeführt und
geschlagen
im moment sind noch nicht so viele leute
auf den straßen zu sehen
ihre zahl wird aber bestimmt steigen vor
ort bei den demos zu sein ist wichtig
für die politische punk künstlerin
normalerweise mal sie auf ihrem tablet
computer und stellt die bilder ins netz
alisa reduziert die figuren aus dem
leben bis auf einfachste künstlerische
gestalten das politische geschehen ist
für die moskauerin die wichtigste
inspiration
in gedanken ist sie bei den
demonstrierenden sobald eine person
auftaucht er die menschen folgen wollen
wird diese person von machthabern
entweder getötet oder eingesperrt
genau das geschieht jetzt mittlerweile
aufgrund seiner popularität setzt er
jetzt im knast in der freigeistig ssten
stadt russlands sankt petersburg gehen
besonders viele menschen auf die straßen
hier ist die polizei auch besonders
brutal selbst gegenüber der presse drei
junge künstlerinnen trauen sich in einem
wohnblock von petersburg ein berg zu
malen
in der heimatstadt von wladimir putin
sprüngen sie ein bild namens geduld
diese ist sichtbar am ende schon nach
wenigen stunden wird diese arbeit von
behörden übermalt wie mehr als 100
frühere werke der künstlergruppe ja hier
im postsowjetischen raum geld leute aus
dem kulturbereich äußern sich nicht über
die politik deswegen gibt es hier
generell nicht so viele politische werke
aber die geschehnisse rund um navalny
bringen immer mehr künstlerinnen dazu
politisch aktiv zu werden
sie bezahlen dafür mit ihrer freiheit 14
tage arrest für diese performance weg
mit dem polizeistaat viele künstlerinnen
äußern sich nur online und posten diese
performance aus jekaterinburg dieses
politische werk heißt stabilität
dafür wird wladimir putin von propaganda
medien gepriesen digitale protest kunst
gewinnt in russland an bedeutung der
moskauer künstler briggs cepacia
verbreitet über die sozialen netzwerke
diese büste von wladimir putin und
projiziert darauf die unsummen die für
sein privatpalast ausgegeben wurden
die staatlichen institutionen können bei
weitem nicht so kreativ auf die
politischen ereignisse reagieren wie wir
selbst mit großen geldern in ihren
budgets der grund ist die korruption wir
sind viel kreativer weil wir auch von
selbst gestellt sind in russischen
sozialen netzwerken macht man sich offen
musste ich über die imperiale
besatzungsarmee putins in russischen
städten aller star wars
die kreml treuen propaganda medien sind
gegen diese lustigen gestalten macht
wird vor allem bei der jungen generation
ein tanz auf dem privaten pump palast
von wladimir putin wie alexei navalny in
seinem letzten film überhaupt
er beschuldigte putin der korruption
rund um den kreml stellt die künstlerin
alisa jaffa ihre aktuellen werke aus
eben virtuell in 3d die bilder sind in
sozialen netzwerken der malerin zu sehen
die künstlerin beschuldigt ganz offen
die russischen machthaber den
oppositionellen navalny vergiftet zu
haben
ein mutiger schritt in putins russland
aufgrund der zensur in museen kann ich
diese bilder nur virtuell ausstellen
für solche werke wurde ein museum eine
strafe bekommen wenn man eine offizielle
ausstellung in russland vereinbart wird
einem gesagt bitte keine religion
politik oder sex als thema aus protest
gegen die machenschaften des kremls geht
die malerin hoffe sobald sich in eine
art performance die haare abzurasieren
in ihrem eigenen atelier folgen draußen
vor dem kreml traut sie sich das nicht
dort würde sie sofort festgenommen
[Musik]